all right BuzzFeed has found the problem
with America you ready according to them
it's white people yes that might be you
a year-end article on the website list
what it says or 37 things white people
need to stop ruining in 2018 among the
listed the Oscars the United States of
America that's a general term
mac-and-cheese I guess are we ruined
that or not sure sneakers Korean pop
music and protests Joe Concha writes for
media for the hill and is also white Joe
so you're a bit responsible here you're
not listed in the 37 where do they get
off coming off the list like this I
think I'm only half white I'm not sure
at least 16 of these things you're
responsible for then so what are they
getting at they're getting at that white
people are bad for this country because
one of them was that white people voted
for Donald Trump at a 58% clip as
opposed to Hillary Clinton at 37 he's an
office there for white people cause this
but let's play a game
okay okay let's swap out white people
ruining America 37 ways and put in black
or Latino or any minority group and you
tell me how BuzzFeed the editor wouldn't
be fired right now ah now every
advertiser on BuzzFeed wouldn't be
boycotted oh yeah believe me after we
saw some of the backlash when the
writers and Vanity Fair came forward and
just had some sarcastic things to say
about Hillary Clinton's terrible
behavior over the last year you saw and
they apologized you can only imagine but
they will they face any backlash from a
list like this you would think but no
that hasn't been happening and they've
done lists like this before there is
precedent one story they wrote was white
people stay colonizing hmm and then
white people are a plague to the planet
was another ones this appears to be a
theme at the BuzzFeed but I got to tell
you your floor director was walking me
out here and he said you know because of
that story I stopped following BuzzFeed
I'm not gonna read it anymore you could
only cross this line so many times
alright so lastly do you think there's a
chance that they're just having fun
they're just like throwing it out there
to get us talking about it dare I say
buzz or do you think there's an agenda I
think they're desperate because I look
at the numbers and they missed their
revenue targets according to The Wall
Street Journal by 50 to 70 million they
were supposed to have an IPO in 2018
most analysts now say that isn't going
to happen so what do you do you try to
stern
pot even more and more and when you do
that you dig the hole deeper and deeper